bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo de pourquoi sont-ils si
uniques aujourd'hui je suis très heureux
car nous allons parler d'un personnage
dont je voulais absolument rendre
hommage pour tout vous dire il a bien
failli même être le sujet de la deuxième
vidéo de pourquoi sont-ils si uniques il
s'agit bien évidemment de Adam Warlock
protagoniste très spécial car pour la
première fois nous n'allons pas traiter
de l'histoire d'un antagoniste mais d'un
héros Adam Warlock est une entité
complètement à part parmi les
super-héros de Marvel à la base prévue
juste pour agrémenter l'univers il a
finalement réussi à se hisser parmi les
plus grandes entités que le Lore de
Marvel n'est jamais connu bon et bien
évidemment je préfère le préciser comme
à chaque fois mais l'histoire du
personnage est très longue et très riche
Adam Warlock se répartit sur plus de 55
ans donc cela en fait comics ou le héros
apparaît ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que le but de l'émission c'est
avant tout de mettre les projecteurs sur
un personnage tout en retraçant son
parcours mais les vidéos seraient quand
même bien trop longues et indigeste si
on traitait de tous les comics dans
lequel le personnage est apparu alors
comme pour les fois précédentes nous
allons faire des sauts dans le temps
pour nous intéresser aux histoires que
j'estime les plus intéressantes et
marquantes et qui démontre du coup
l'unicité de notre héros sur ce si vous
êtes prêts parlons de l'être
artificielle qui a été élu par les êtres
cosmiques pour défendre la vie voyons
ensemble pourquoi Adam Warlock et
cynique
[Musique]
nous sommes le 8 juin
1967 et le comics 66 des 4 Fantastiques
nous comptent une nouvelle histoire qui
va aboutir sur l'émergence d'un drôle de
personnage créé pour être puissant et
parfait alors que le célèbre groupe de
super-héros est à la recherche d'Alicia
Masters fraîchement absente de son
domicile et qui est pour information la
compagne de bengrim alias la chose il se
trouve en fait que cette dernière a été
emmenée à l'insu de tous dans une base
très secrète nommée le BeHive que l'on
pourrait traduire par la ruche
accueillie par trois grands
scientifiques le comics va nous révéler
kalysia a été kidnappé pour remplir une
mission très spéciale en réalité les
scientifiques de la ruche ont souhaité
concevoir une nouvelle forme de vie
artificielle malheureusement après des
années de travail ce nouvel être c'est
rebeller face à ses créateurs et c'est
enfermé au plus profond du laboratoire
empêchant quiconque d'approcher grâce à
sa lumière aveuglante ni une ni deux
Alicia comprend très vite la raison de
sa présence effectivement alicia est
aveugle mais en plus de cela elle est
une experte de la sculpture ce qui veut
dire que cette dernière peut parcourir
le laboratoire et façonner une statue à
l'effigie de la nouvelle forme de vie
conçue par la ruche leur permettant de
voir à quoi ressemble leur création
équipée et accompagnées par Hamilton
l'un des scientifiques du laboratoire
secret Alicia avance petit à petit dans
les profondeurs du bâtiment après
quelques péripéties la jeune femme fera
face à un cocon il nous sera révélé que
l'être à l'intérieur du cocon a permis à
Alicia de le rencontrer car il sent dans
son cœur qu'elle est une bonne personne
et qu'elle a de réels bonnes intentions
contrairement à ces créateurs
les actions de données naissance à une
nouvelle forme de vie artificielle
traduite en réalité un plan
machiavélique rempli de mauvaises
intentions à terme lettres à l'intérieur
du cocon va nous révéler qu'il se sent
seul et désarmé Alicia va leur assurer
mais au même moment Hamilton va arriver
pour tuer la progéniture de la ruche car
en réalité les scientifiques craignent
la toute-puissance de leur création dont
le contrôle semble leur échapper l'être
va répliquer en tuant le scientifique et
les quatre fantastiques qui ont
finalement retrouvé la trace d'Alicia
vont venir secourir la jeune femme après
ce sauvetage le cocon va finalement
s'ouvrir et un homme tout doré va en
sortir nous sommes témoins de la
naissance de l'entité nommée lui seul
avec ses créateurs le personnage va nous
avouer qu'il n'a rien à faire sur la
terre et pour prévenir le futur des
mauvaises intentions de la ruche il va
anéantir la place que représente les
scientifiques avant de quitter la
planète deux ans plus tard dans le
comics 165 de la saga Thor sorti en 1969
lui va réapparaître alors que le dieu du
tonnerre et Lady CIF sortent d'une
grande bataille en plein New York face à
Hadès qui convoitait un certain centre
de recherche atomique un étrange
personnage au même moment se met à
sortir d'un mystérieux cocon qui
reposait dans ce même centre il s'agit
bien évidemment de lui et il semblerait
que le personnage soit tout autant
surpris que nous de savoir qu'il se
retrouve une fois de plus sur terre
alors qu'il l'avait normalement quitté
face à tort le personnage va se
présenter et nous raconter ce qu'il
s'est passé depuis son apparition dans
la saga fantastique fort une fois les
membres de la ruche assassinés lui s'en
est allé dans l'espace malheureusement
en parcourant les étoiles il s'est
heurté à un drôle de rassemblement
d'astéroïdes ce qu'il a obligé
retourner dans son cocon pour se
régénérer et là quelque chose de très
surprenant va se produire alors que le
cocon de lui est en train de dériver
dans l'espace un vaisseau spatial va
arriver et faire la découverte de ce
dernier il s'agit en fait du Watchers un
être cosmique dont l'existence se résume
à observer la galaxie et l'histoire de
l'Univers l'être qui se fait appeler lui
à en réalité atterri dans un piège
orchestré par le Watchers qui voulait
simplement attraper des astéroïdes pour
les étudier normalement l'être cosmique
ayant pour devoir de simplement regarder
ne doit en aucun cas intervenir dans la
galaxie mais face à cet accident le
Watchers va décider de mettre ce drôle
de cocon à l'abri dans un satellite
américain qui a pour but de revenir sur
terre dans les plus brefs délais de
retour dans le présent Thor et lui
commencent à avoir une conversation car
le dieu du tonnerre a envie de
comprendre qui est ce nouveau personnage
et quels sont ses intentions cependant
n'ayant aucune connaissance de la vie ou
des émotions l'être créé par la ruche va
se comporter d'une manière jugée plutôt
anormale pour tout être humain ou vivant
civilisé lui ce sang seul et pour cela
il aimerait avoir quelqu'un pour
l'accompagner dans son existence très
attiré par CIF qui est l'amour actuel de
Thor lui va souhaiter s'emparer de la
jeune femme et il va la kidnapper malgré
les désaccords des autres personnages
une course poursuite va alors s'engager
et Thor va retrouver la trace de lui sur
un autre monde malencontreusement pour
l'être artificiel qui ne comprend pas ce
qu'il a fait de mal Thor est
actuellement atteint de ce qu'on appelle
sur Asgard la folie des guerriers ce qui
fait que le fils d'Odin est très
irritable et facilement énervé lui va
alors se prendre toute la rage du dieu
du tonnerre alors qu'il voulait
simplement ne plus être seul vaincu le
personnage n'aura que pour solution de
se replacer dans son cocon et s'isoler
nouveau dans l'espace faisons un premier
point ici car il y a beaucoup de choses
très intéressantes à dire sur ces deux
premiers comics alors que l'on nous fait
part d'une origine Story qui aboutit sur
une ouverture avec l'arrivée du
personnage dans l'immensité de l'espace
on s'attend normalement à ce que par la
suite Marvel passe la vitesse supérieure
concernant lui pourtant nous le
retrouvons seulement deux ans plus tard
dans le comics d'une autre saga et il
est encore une fois de retour sur terre
malgré lui et bien en fait cela traduit
à un véritable problème des dessinateurs
ils ne savent pas quoi faire de ce
personnage et ce dernier va même passer
de main en main parmi les écrivains de
chez Marvel et ce jusqu'en
1972 car oui après ce comics où lui a
confronté Thor nous allons encore avoir
une absence du personnage qui va durer
pendant trois ans et d'ailleurs en
parlant du comics de Thor ce dernier
traduit véritablement ce souci de par
l'intervention du Watchers qui est un
être cosmique il peut être du coup
représenté ici par les créateurs de
Marvel eux-mêmes et du coup bah à cause
du Watchers lui va faire trois pas en
arrière il sera ramené sur terre à cause
du Watchers alors qu'il est prête à
avancer dans son histoire il est tout
simplement ramené à la case départ et
c'est un peu pareil pour le cocon c'est
un peu une sorte de cheat code pour
dégager le personnage pendant un certain
temps et le ramener une fois
l'inspiration trouvée dites-vous que les
débuts d'Adam Warlock sont tellement
décousus que pour beaucoup de fans ses
premiers comics dont je vous ai parlé
ils ne sont pas véritablement à
considérer comme première apparition du
personnage pour certains Adam va
réellement naître dans le prochain
comics dont nous allons parler ce qui
n'est pas totalement faux en soi et
justement il est temps d'amener ce
comics heureusement pour les lecteurs de
l'époque c'était particulière qui a duré
5 ans et désormais révolue car à partir
de maintenant l'histoire de lui va
changer à tout jamais par dès à présent
de la saga Marvel première tout d'abord
il faut savoir que la saga Marvel
première est une série de comics plutôt
spécifique effectivement ces dernières a
pour utilité au créateurs défectuer des
comics d'essai c'est à dire proposer des
concepts inédits prolongés ou apporter
des nouvelles histoires de personnages
bref que des trucs qu'ils n'osent pas
tenter d'habitude puis après Marvel
prend la température voit ce que les
lecteurs ont préféré dans ce qui a été
proposé puis on adapte par la suite ce
qui a marché et c'est plutôt marrant car
bizarrement les deux premiers comics de
Marvel première sont centrés sur Adam
Warlock donc c'est à se demander si ce
concept de comics d'essai n'aurait pas
vu le jour à la base juste pour lui
depuis son vaisseau en forme
d'astéroïdes le maître de l'évolution de
son vrai nom Herbert et profondément
plongée dans ses pensées ce génie de la
génétique repense à ses créations et à
tout ce qu'il a accompli cependant ce
dernier sera très vite coupé de sa
méditation car son bras droit va le
prévenir qu'il a découvert un drôle de
cocon en train de dériver dans l'espace
très curieux de savoir ce qu'il contient
le maître de l'évolution va leur ramener
dans son vaisseau désireux de la
perfection il fantasme sur le fait que
ce cocon pourrait possiblement cacher le
fils génétiquement supérieur qu'il n'a
jamais eu c'est alors que lui va
intervenir et se présenter une fois sa
courte histoire racontée le personnage
va émettre le souhait de retourner dans
l'espace car il n'est pas encore prêt à
émerger Herbert n'y voit aucun
inconvénient lui n'étant apparemment pas
une menace pour son projet alpha il n'y
a aucun problème à le laisser partir
mais alors qu'il est prête à se
rendormir la curiosité de lui va
s'éveiller à la mention du projet alpha
les deux hommes vont finalement
commencer à entamer une conversation
et le maître de l'évolution va expliquer
sa nouvelle œuvre herberte souhaite
donner naissance à une nouvelle planète
Terre où l'instinct de tueur des hommes
n'existerait pas grâce à sa technologie
et ses pouvoirs le maître va entamer son
projet sous les yeux de lui par le biais
d'un morceau de rocher provenant de la
terre le maître de l'évolution va donner
naissance à la contre terre et apporter
la vie en la faisant avancer de
plusieurs milliards d'années pour
atteindre l'air de l'homme moderne mais
contre toute attente l'une des plus
vieilles créations d'Herbert va faire
son intervention il s'agit du manne
Beast une sorte d'homelot qui s'est
rebellie contre son créateur prise au
dépourvu le maître de l'évolution est
surmené lui va alors prendre la décision
d'intervenir pour le sauver battu le
manbiste va quitter le vaisseau pour se
cacher sur la contre terre herberte va
alors souhaiter détruire son œuvre dans
le but que sa création des viandes meurt
dans le processus car il a peur que ce
dernier coron peut sa nouvelle création
sauf que lui va s'interposer inquiet
pour les hommes de la contre terre lui
va proposer d'aller traquer lui-même le
Mans Beast afin d'éviter que leur
créateur ne fassent un massacre
herberthe va alors nous faire part qu'il
a finalement trouvé le fils qu'il a
toujours souhaité il va offrir à lui une
drôle d'émeraude pour accroître les
pouvoirs de son nouvel allié mais
surtout il va le baptiser à partir de
maintenant lui aura pour nom Warlock
quelques temps plus tard réveillé sur la
contre terre par quatre adolescents
interloqués à la vue de ce drôle d'homme
à la peau doré il nous sera révélé que
notre héros a finalement perdu la
mémoire et que la seule chose dont il se
rappelle c'est que dans son passé
quelqu'un l'avait nommé Warlock les
jeunes gens possédant tous de noms vont
donc trouver à Warlock une seconde
appellation pour compléter son premier
nom désormais Warlock aura pour
Adam une fois ces esprits retrouvés le
personnage va par la suite faire la
rencontre des habitants de la contre
terre et alors qu'une drôle de bête
anthropomorphe intervient pour menacer
les habitants Adam valait défendre et
finira à terme par retrouver la mémoire
après avoir fait ses preuves via les
deux premiers comics de Marvel première
Adam aura enfin sa première saga
principale j'ai nommé Warlock et vous
allez le voir mais il semble que la
trajectoire prévue pour Adam ce serait
d'en faire une sorte de héros
prophétique vous allez beaucoup plus
vous en rendre compte par la suite mais
Marvel première a en fait instaurer les
bases d'une histoire que l'on connaît
déjà tous le maître de l'évolution est
semblable à un dieu un Dieu qui a créé
la terre nommé ici la contre terre et
Adam kerbert te désigne comme son fils a
pour mission d'aller sauver les hommes
de la contre terre du méchant man Beast
une sorte de bête Ant que l'on pourrait
comparer au diable alors qu'Adam
appréhende sa nouvelle vie sur la contre
terre le maître de l'évolution souhaite
toujours au fond de lui détruire sa
création néanmoins il n'oublie pas la
promesse qu'il a faite à son champion
par conséquent Herbert te va convoquer
Adam pour s'entretenir avec lui
comparable à un Dieu qui s'entretient
avec son élu Adam va nous rappeler des
ce premier comics sa condition de Messi
et le maître de l'évolution choisira de
croire en lui cette saga de comics va
permettre à Adam d'évoluer et
d'installer sa nouvelle trajectoire le
personnage continuera de répandre le
bien il réussira même apparemment à tuer
le même Beast et sa vie sur la contre
terre lui permettra d'appréhender de
nouvelles émotions d'acquérir de
l'expérience bref Adam Warlock évolue et
comprend tout doucement le concept de la
vie néanmoins à terme il sera révélé que
le Mans Beast était toujours en vie et
agissait dans l'ombre ce dernier était
en fait dans la peau du président des
États-Unis et par conséquent cela veut
dire que lui et ses hommes possèdent les
pleins pouvoirs du pays c'est alors que
au même moment Hulk qui a été banni dans
l'espace vient d'atterrir sur la
Contre-Terre ni une ni deux le même
Beast va voir une opportunité de se
débarrasser d'Adam Warlock son ennemi
juré à tout jamais l'antagoniste va
implanter un appareil obligeant Hulk à
lui obéir au doigt et à l’œil et à
partir de ce moment l'histoire qui nous
sera comptée est une allégorie complète
du Nouveau Testament de la Bible
quelques temps plus tard Hulk va
retrouver Adam worlock qu'il connaît
déjà de part de précédents comics tel
une reproduction de la scène nous
montrant Adam en train de souper avec
ses apôtres et Hulk en tant cavité
Banner représentant Judas sous le
contrôle du man Beast va détruire la
table et kidnapper Adam Warlock pour
l'amener à son maître ayant usurpé
l'identité du président américain Le
Mans Beast va faire une élocution pour
annoncer la mise à mort public du
dangereux Adam worlock pour ses nombreux
crimes notre héros sera alors à terme
crucifié et mis à mort à la vue de tous
décédé Adam va retourner dans son cocon
réalisant ce qu'il vient de se passer
sous ses yeux Hulk va rentrer dans une
tristesse et une colère noire il va tuer
de nombreux hommes du même Beast et
kidnappé le cocon d’adam pour le ramener
auprès des partisans du défunt héros
après le décès de Warlock le même bis va
en profiter pour se dévoiler au grand
jour et prendre le contrôle de la contre
terre pendant près de trois jours la
planète va connaître une véritable
guerre civile Hulk affrontera même le
Mans Beast à lui tout seul cependant
c'est à ce moment que tout va changer
car à la surprise générale Adam Warlock
vient de renaître et il va s'interposer
dans le combat pour juger le manne Beast
de ses actes notre héros va surpasser
son ennemi et le réduire à simple état
d'animal le manne Beast n'est désormais
qu'un simple loup et alors que tout le
monde est prêt à fêter cette victoire
Adam nous explique que pendant son
absence il a une fois de plus évolué et
a pris conscience que beaucoup d'autres
auraient besoin de lui à travers
l'univers la contre terre n'ayant
désormais plus de menaces notre héros
est prêt à parcourir l'horizon pour
apporter son aide à ceux dans le besoin
en fait à ce moment là via les comics
incredible hulk le personnage d'Adam
Warlock va encore une fois passer dans
de nouvelles mains Roy Thomas et Gilles
Kane ont instauré cette ambiance de
héros
prophètes/messy et désormais James
Starling aller reprendre Adam Warlock en
main et lui proposer de nouvelles
aventures il a bien aimé du coup ce
coinstaurer les précédents artistes et
du coup désormais bah il est temps de
prolonger tout ça vers l'immensité de
l'espace Adam doit quitter la contre
terre et c'est pourquoi ils s'en va de
manière abrupte à la fin de incredible
hulk 178 en réalité bien que nous soyons
face à une sorte de première conclusion
de l'histoire d'Adam Warlock les comics
incredible hulk vont en fait servir
plutôt d'introduction à ce que Jim
Sterlin a en tête nous arrivons
désormais à l'aube de la megas saga nous
dans le comics strange tails numéro 178
sortie le 26 novembre
1974 et une jeune femme est actuellement
en train de se faire courser par de
monstrueuses créatures par chance Adam
Warlock passé par là et ce dernier va
s'interposer pour sauver la jeune femme
contre toute attente la rescapé
reconnaît notre héros elle sait qui est
Adam Warlock et nous informe qu'elle a
parcouru un très long chemin pour le
trouver car apparemment lui seul serait
en capacité d'aider le peuple dont elle
provient ne comprenant pas réellement
tout ce qu'il se passe Adam sera
interloquée de la situation dans
laquelle il vient de se mettre il sera
fait mention d'église universelle de la
vérité de grand inquisiteurs d'infidèles
de maygues bref on ne comprend rien quoi
et en plus de cela les créatures vont
tuer la jeune femme avant de disparaître
pour cADAM n'est aucune information mais
via la pierre présente sur son front qui
est enfin désigné comme la gemme de
l'âme Adam va pouvoir temporairement
ramener la jeune femme à la vie pour
qu'elle lui explique ce qu'il se passe
cette dernière va nous révéler qu'elle
vient d'un monde guider et orchestrée
par une certaine religion dont le Dieu
tout-puissant vénéré serait incertain
maigre ou magous si vous préférez le
prononcer en latin et le véritable
problème c'est que de là où elle vient
énormément de gens sont persécutés ou
sont des esclaves seuls les endoctriner
par l'Église universelle ont le droit à
la vie et à la liberté grâce au pouvoir
de la pierre de l'âme Adam va comprendre
que la femme dit vrai en sont dans son
esprit s'étant donné pour mission
d'aider les gens dans le besoin ce
dernier est prête à entamer cette
nouvelle quête c'est alors qu'une
projection astrale de Mega se lui-même
va apparaître et grosse révélation
l'entité diabolique va nous expliquer
qu'il est en fait lui aussi Adam Warlock
mais
un Warlock du futur qui a pris un autre
chemin un chemin à l'opposé des valeurs
de notre Adam worlock choqué par ce
qu'il vient de se passer et souhaitant
avoir des réponses Adam partira
désormais à la traque de ma gueule au
fil des péripéties notre héros parcourta
les infrastructures appartenant à
l'Église universelle il libérera des
prisonniers dont un certain pipe le
troll qui va commencer à le seconder
dans ses aventures Adam tu auras
d'ailleurs pour la première fois
quelqu'un avec la pierre de l'âme ce qui
va énormément le troubler et nous aurons
également l'intégration d'un nouveau
personnage incarné par une mystérieuse
femme à la peau verte qui répond au nom
de gamora à terme de retour dans sa
série principale Adam Warlock accompagné
de pipe et gamora feront finalement face
à megus le vilain va nous montrer qu'il
a en fait tout orchestré pour arriver à
ce moment précis toute la récente quête
d'Adam Warlock était en fait qu'une
manipulation de ma gueule le prétendu
Dieu met en fait tout en œuvre pour
respecter la boucle temporelle dans
laquelle il a vu le jour et pour se
faire il doit neutraliser Adam Warlock
pour qu'ensuite ligne b'twinner une
entité cosmique symbolisant l'équilibre
on pourrait le symboliser d'ailleurs
comme l'entre-deux ou l'intermédiaire
entre l'ordre et le chaos lui trace la
route pour devenir à terme makes Adam
worlock et dépassé par les événements il
n'accepte pas le fait qu'il soit destiné
à devenir une entité aussi maléfique que
le make us en plus de cela lui qui a été
conditionné en tant que Messi sur la
contre terre a délivrer les gens du mal
à aujourd'hui causé la mort de deux
personnes par le biais de la gemme de
l'âme j'aime dont il essaye tant bien
que mal de résister car ces dernières
essayent également de corrompre Adam
Warlock est alors au fond du trou tout
ce qu'il voulait
provoquer le bien mais finalement la
contrepartie de tout ça c'est qu'il
incarne le mal et son futur lui-même le
prouve mais alors que tout espoir semble
perdu gamora qui était en fait en
mission secrète a appelé son maître à la
rescousse Thanos rejoint donc le combat
et vient pour sauver Adam Warlock après
une longue cavale et plusieurs
affrontements entre notre équipe et mega
sa compagnie de ses hommes nous allons
enfin avoir des réponses sur tout ce
qu'il se passe et attention je vous
conseille de bien vous accrocher Thanos
cependant la bataille va convaincre Adam
Warlock que la seule et unique solution
pour vaincre megus et que notre héros
met un terme à sa propre existence et
pour cela le Titan a tout prévu dans son
vaisseau se trouve une sonde temporelle
qui permettrait à Adam d'effacer son
destin et par conséquent son propre
futur n'ayant pas peur de la mort
toujours prête à se sacrifier et quand
la bonne volonté de Thanos Adam va
plonger dans ce mystérieux portail
là-bas contre toute attente ligne
betwinner est déjà présent et attend
l'arrivée du protagoniste bien
évidemment Adam le considère directement
comme un ennemi et tente par tous les
moyens de le confronter cependant l'être
cosmique veut rassurer notre héros si ce
dernier est présent pour le rencontrer
c'est pour une bonne raison ligne
betweener comprend pourquoi Warlock lui
en veut megus est très particulier et en
réalité ce personnage est un peu un
imprévu en fait l'équilibre entre la vie
et la mort est actuellement perturbé
ligne betwinner nous apprend que
récemment un champion de la mort a fait
son apparition et étant l'être cosmique
en charge de l'équilibre ce dernier a dû
trouver une solution et cette solution a
été de désigner un champion de la vie et
bien évidemment vous l'a compris mais
c'est Adam worlock qui a été choisi pour
être ce fameux champion malheureusement
ligne betwinner a fait face à un imprévu
cette condition de champion a
déséquilibrer l'esprit d'Adam Warlock et
à terme c'est comme ça qu'il est devenu
le terrible make us meilleur est donc le
champion de la vie mais ce dernier est
doté d'un esprit infâme et vicieux notre
Adam Warlock va alors tout comprendre il
ne peut échapper au fait qu'il soit
désigné comme le champion de la vie
néanmoins il peut esquiver son futur en
tant que megus depuis la sonde
temporelle notre héros fera face à 5
chemins traduisant 5 lignes du futur du
personnage grâce à la pierre de l'âme
Adam va détruire le chemin traduisant
l'existence du meilleur pour le tuer et
va par la suite emprunter le chemin le
plus court qui le conduira 2 ans dans le
futur là-bas il fera face à un autre
Adam Warlock qui commence tout lentement
à devenir aigri ce dernier attendait la
venue de son lui du passé pour enfin
mourir car sinon il allait commencer
petit à petit à devenir le terrible ma
gueule notre Adam Warlock va alors se
servir de sa gêne pour prendre l'âme du
Adam du futur de retour dans le présent
mais que c'est Thanos sont en train de
s'affronter seul à seul très surpris de
voir que le Titan avait en fait tout
planifié mégaus qui est le champion de
la vie va comprendre au final que si
Thanos a sauvé Adam pour éviter sa
terrible destinée c'est parce que le
Titan est en réalité le champion de la
mort mais malheureusement il n'aura pas
le temps d'agir car vu qu'Adam a détruit
sa ligne temporelle make us va commencer
à disparaître le plan de Thanos a
fonctionné son rival le champion de la
vie n'existe plus sans le savoir notre
Adam Warlock a donné à Thanos
la victoire
la saga du meilleur est possiblement le
moment le plus important de la vie
d'Adam Warlock c'est une histoire auquel
on ne s'attend pas tout le monde très
vite de manière très crescendo de
manière très complexe et pourtant c'est
quelque chose qui va instaurer beaucoup
de base pour la future apogée de notre
héros toujours dans cette idéologie de
faire dAdam Warlock un messie une sorte
d'élus de l'univers Marvel Jim Sterlin a
étendu ce concept or de la contre terre
le fait que l'inbit winner qui est un
être cosmique donc l'une des entités
au-dessus de tout de l'univers Marvel et
choisi Adam pour être champion de la vie
et ben cela démontre complètement
l'unicité de notre héros Adam n'est pas
n'importe qui il est le seul capable de
renverser Thanos le seul capable de
faire face à la mort il est le plus pur
de tous les héros intéressant mais la
venue de Thanos en tant que champion de
la mort nous tisse du coup une future
liaison entre Adam et le Titan nous le
verrons plus clairement par la suite
mais c'est en fait l'installation d'un
nouveau rival pour Adam Warlock car en
tant qu'incarnation du bien et bien du
coup il faut une incarnation du mal pour
s'opposer à lui et sincèrement Thanos
rempli à merveille ce rôle les deux
personnages vont beaucoup s'apporter au
fil des histoires et leurs relations
apportera beaucoup de profondeur nous
reverrons par la suite Adam Warlock
toujours dans sa série principale notre
héros sera ramené dans sa temporalité où
il pourra continuer à vivre ses
aventures il sera notamment confronté à
un certain voleur d'étoiles en quête de
réponse sur son destin il sera amené
également à rencontrer un drôle de
voyageur qui lui parlera de son avenir
et enfin Adam confrontera carrément la
pierre de l'âme elle-même présente sur
son front pour mieux la connaître dans
Marvel team up 55
fera aussi la rencontre de Spider-Man
qui est actuellement perdue dans
l'espace mais l'histoire qui va
désormais réellement nous intéresser
c'est le comics annuel numéro 7 des
Avengers nous retrouvons Adam Warlock
qui vient de trouver gamora au bord de
la mort l'ami de notre héros a été
trahie par son maître Thanos gamora a en
fait découvert le véritable plan du
Titan celui de propager la mort à
travers tout l'univers et voulant
empêcher son maître d'arriver à ses fins
gamora a tenté de l'arrêter en vain dans
les derniers instants de la jeune femme
Adam va aspirer son âme grâce à sa gêne
et notre héros entrera dans une profonde
amertume il va véritablement comprendre
que Thanos l'avait à l'époque bernée le
meilleur a été tué pour que le Titan fou
puisse enfin arriver à son but désormais
conscient qu'en tant que champion de la
vie il est naturelle et ultime de Thanos
le protagoniste doit agir et ce dans les
plus brefs délais désireux de venger son
ami gamora dont le décès traduit la
provocation de la mort contre la vie
Warlock va réunir le célèbre groupe des
Avengers se pour l'aider dans sa quête
il sait que l'équipe a déjà fait face au
Titan par le passé et qu'il crée son
retour Adam va d'ailleurs nous révéler
que Thanos est actuellement en
possession des 6 gemmes de l'âme
instrument de la mort qui lui
permettrait de se hisser au rang de Dieu
il sera d'ailleurs expliqué qu'à
l'époque pendant le combat contre megus
Thanos a réussi à siphonner les pouvoirs
de la gemme d'Adam pour en créer une
synthétique copiant les propriétés de
l'originelle une fois la trame mise en
place les Avengers se vont se rendre
compte que le plan de Thanos est déjà
mis en oeuvre Adam va alors partir en
quête du Titan malheureusement il va
faire la lourde découverte que son
meilleur ami PIP a été tué de la main de
Thanos comme provocation envers le
nouveau champion de la vie Adam
bouleversée va se servir de la gêne de
l'âme pour sonder l'esprit de son défunt
compagnon ayant désormais grâce à pipe
la localisation de Thanos Adam
accompagnée de Captain Marvel par pour
confronter le Titan mais au final Adam
Warlock va échouer Thanos va le battre
néanmoins les Avengers arrivaient à la
dernière seconde réussiront quand même
tant bien que mal à vaincre le Titan et
détruire sa gemme synthétique obligeant
Thanos à s'enfuir à partir de ce moment
quelque chose de très surprenant va se
produire Captain Marvel qui est en train
de chercher Adam dans les décombres sera
à sa grande surprise témoin de la
présence non pas Dana Warlock mais de
deux nous sommes en fait face à la scène
présente dans Warlock numéro 11
mais cette fois-ci sous le point de vue
du Adam du futur effectivement
rappelez-vous mais quand Adam Warlock a
stoppé l'existence du make us il est
ensuite parti dans un cours futur où il
a rencontré un autre Adam aigri de la
vie qui était à l'aube de sa
transformation en make us et bien nous y
sommes à ce moment depuis les événements
avec ligne betwinner notre Adam Warlock
attendait la venue de son lui du passé
pour lui éviter de se transformer en
mégus à l'époque Warlock a en fait conçu
une autre boucle temporelle pour éviter
que le megus existe un jour ou l'autre
très en colère de son existence qu'il
considère comme un échec car en tant que
champion de la vie tout ce qu'il a connu
au final c'est la mort le chagrin et la
perte de ses amis notre Adam Warlock a
finalement hâte de trouver la paix car
d'après son vécu la vie est beaucoup
plus effrayante que la mort les émotions
sont trop dur à gérer le Adam du passé
comme le veut la boucle temporelle
instaurer va donc tuer notre Adam avec
la pierre de l'âme cependant à sa grande
surprise Adam Warlock n'est pas
réellement mort son âme a été aspirée
dans la gêne là-bas le protagoniste bat
en fait arriver dans une sorte de
paradis et retrouvera ses deux amis
gamora et pipe mais ce n'est pas tout il
va également retrouver tous les gens
qu'il a affronté pendant sa bataille
contre le megus libéré du fardeau de la
vie Adam et ses compagnons se sentent
léger une nouvelle ère de bonheur arrive
enfin à partir de ce moment c'est un
petit peu particulier car bien
évidemment vous l'aurez compris mais il
n'y a plus d'Adam Warlock puisque celui
du passé est retourné justement à son
époque et que notre Adam est désormais
dans la de l'âme et pire que ça ce n'est
pas montré dans le comics Méthanos après
son combat va récupérer la pierre de
l'âme sur le corps d’adam du coup tout
ça cela va créer un déséquilibre entre
l'ordre et le chaos Adam n'est plus donc
plus de champion de la vie et de l'autre
côté Thanos champion de la mort et tout
puissant et prête à en découdre tout ça
va obliger les entités cosmiques de
l'ordre et du chaos d'intervenir dans le
comics Marvel twin one annuel numéro 1
ou Spider Man guidé inconsciemment par
les êtres divins libérera Adam Warlock
pour anéantir Thanos une bonne fois pour
toute et en soi nous faisons face ici à
une conclusion de l'histoire d'Adam
Warlock le personnage est désormais mort
et en paix Thanos a été vaincu et n'est
plus une menace donc voilà nous
pourrions nous arrêter ici cependant
contre toute attente notre héros va
réapparaître en
1991 soit près de 14 ans plus tard
Thanos a été ressuscité par la mort
elle-même et ce dernier c'est de nouveau
remis en quête d'obtenir les gemmes qui
cette fois-ci vont enfin prendre leur
identité de pierre de l'infini le Titan
va même créer un gant pour l'occasion
capable d'unir le pouvoir de ces
dernières sauf que pendant son périple
le Titan fou a croisé la route du
surfeur d'argent et de drague le
destructeur et durant leur affrontement
Thanos va se servir de la gêne de l'âme
pour les tuer tous les deux du coup
l'âme de nos deux protagonistes
atterriront dans le Soul World le monde
où siège Adam Warlock et il nous sera
montré que notre héros est désormais en
symbiose avec la pierre de l'âme dont il
est intimement lié depuis qu'elle lui a
été conféré par le maître de l'évolution
le Surfeur d'Argent va du coup pouvoir
expliquer la situation à Warlock et
notre héros ramènera le surfeur ainsi
que Drax dans leur corps originel ce qui
va permettre par la suite à nos inrad
d'aller
tire les Avengers de la menace grondante
que symbolise Thanos le Titan fou équipé
de la plus grande puissance que
l'univers n'est jamais connu va à terme
effectuer le fameux snap pour
impressionner la mort et la moitié des
êtres vivants de l'univers va
disparaître ne pouvant éviter son rôle
de défenseur de la vie et sachant son
terrible rivales ramenées Adam va
finalement revenir pour contrecarrer les
plans du Titan et guider les Avengers
vers la victoire ce qui ignore Thanos
c'est que désormais Adam la mentalement
surpassée le protagoniste malgré sa mort
c'est énormément développé grâce à la
pierre de l'âme dans laquelle il est
resté à l'intérieur pendant près de 14
ans et en plus de cela vu que Thanos
s'en est servi à maintes reprises et
bien notre héros c'est désormais les
moindres émotions du Titan il connaît
toute son histoire ses intentions ses
peurs tout ce qui symbolise son âme en
gros et il va servir pour le déjouer
après avoir réuni derrière lui la
totalité des Avengers et les plus grands
êtres cosmiques qui composent l'univers
nous offrons au passage l'une des plus
grandes batailles de l'univers Marvel
Adam va finalement à terme réussir à
reprendre le gant de l'infini et
s'ériger en tant que nouveau dieu Thanos
vaincu Adam choisira de ne pas tuer le
Titan et le conduira sur une planète
secrète ou ce dernier pourra vivre
paisiblement ce qui est intéressant avec
la saga du gant de l'infini ce n'est pas
tant que ça la bataille en elle-même
bien qu'elle soit très spectaculaire
mais plutôt la montée en puissance
d'Adam Warlock et au final ce qui lui a
permis de gagner après n'avoir fait
qu'un avec la pierre de l'âme qui est
une force de l'infini et étant plus de
cela le champion de la vie choisi par
les êtres cosmiques Warlock est
désormais un véritable Messi de
l'univers Marvel il est le seul
personnage capable d'unir à la fois tous
les héros de Marvel et les dieux
cosmiques de l'univers néanmoins autre
point intéressant c'est que la victoire
ne sera pas obtenue que grâce à la
puissance du gant de l'infini mais tout
simplement car Adam parle biais de la
gemme de l'âme connaît profondément son
ennemi Thanos contrairement à Adam
Warlock qui est un être artificiel n'est
qu'un simple être vivant et malgré ses
récents pouvoirs divins ce dernier est
quand même sujet au doute à l'anxiété ou
bien tout simplement l'amour bref c'est
un être victime de ses émotions et Adam
Warlock Asus en servir pour le battre et
enfin élément qui pèse son poids c'est
que profondément attaché à ses valeurs
Adam Warlock ne tuera pas Thanos il est
sûr que ce dernier peut changer et du
coup il le placera là où il pourra
garder un oeil sur lui pour ne rien vous
cacher cette courte saga de comics sera
un véritable succès chez les lecteurs et
Adam Warlock étant le personnage
principal de cette épopée
Voltera les lauriers de cette histoire
ce qui va résulter du coup par la suite
de nombreux comics le mettant en vedette
déjà nous pouvons faire mention de la
série de comics Warlock and the infinity
watch sorti des février 1992 qui est la
suite directe de la saga du gant de
l'infini Adam toujours en possession du
gant et des pierres se retrouvera face
au tribunal vivant jugeant que notre
héros est trop instable pour conserver
un tel pouvoir ou arlock dispersera
alors les gemmes entre les gens en qui
la confiance et surprenamment Thanos
héritera de la pierre de réalité c'est
la naissance de l'Infinity watch une
équipe où chaque membre possède une
pierre de l'infini et cette saga durera
jusqu'en 95 mais nous aurons également
d'autres mini-séries comme Infinity war
sorti en avril 92 ou Thanos et Adam
Warlock seront réunis avec les membres
de l'Infinity watch pour contrer le
retour de make us ou encore Infinity
crosside en 1993 où cette fois-ci ils
feront face à la déesse en gros petite
explication mais au moment où Adam
Warlock tenait le gant de l'infini avec
les pierres en tant que nouveau dieu il
ne voulait pas comme Thanos être sujet à
ses émotions car c'est ce qui lui a fait
perdre et du coup il a voulu expulser de
son corps tout le bien et tout le mal
qu'il incarnait ce qui a redonné
naissance par conséquent à megus
symbolisant le mal d'Adam Warlock et
godes symbolisant le bien bref vous
l'aurez compris au fil de la vidéo mais
l'évolution d'Adam Warlock est très
crescendo voir sans limite que ce soit
dans l'univers Marvel mais aussi en tant
que héros de comics là où le personnage
était clairement un poids mort dont
personne ne trouvait d'histoire à lui
raconter dès les années 90 il va
multiplier ses apparitions devenant l'un
des héros les plus appréciés terminons
du coup maintenant cette vidéo avec une
dernière histoire mais avant ça il faut
que je vous pose une certaine base Adam
Warlock a énormément évolué à tel point
que ce dernier ainsi que son rival de
toujours Thanos ne peuvent plus être
considérés sur le même plan astral que
les autres personnages ils sont tous
deux des élus des êtres cosmiques ils
sont tous les deux maintenant reliés à
l'univers l'un et l'incarnation de la
vie tandis que l'autre est celle de la
mort mais voilà cette condition est
aussi une sorte de poids de fardeau
alors que nos deux personnages sont
naturellement fait pour être des ennemis
leurs conditions de champion les rendent
également uniques dans l'univers et
justement c'est quelque chose qui va les
rapprocher Thanos et le seul à
comprendre les mots d'Adam worlock
reliés à l'existence et l'univers car
lui aussi possède cette même sensibilité
ce même fardeau et c'est une profondeur
que j'aime beaucoup et que nous allons
retrouver de 19 11 a aujourd'hui et
cette dernière histoire que je vais vous
partager traduit complètement tout ça
quelque chose se trame dans l'existence
il y a comme une sorte de chamboulement
dans l'univers un déséquilibre se faire
ressentir et cela inquiète les êtres
cosmiques et le truc c'est que comme je
vous le disais précédemment Thanos est
quelqu'un de très spécial dans l'univers
et du coup il va lui aussi sentir cette
perturbation ainsi qu'à dam Warlock
fraîchement ramené à la vie par la mort
elle-même pour l'occasion nos deux
personnages étant les seuls êtres
vivants à ressentir que quelque chose
qui les dépasse ce tram vont commencer à
retravailler ensemble pour éclaircir la
situation ce qui va même les pousser à
rencontrer le Thanos et le Adam Warlock
d'un autre univers qui eux aussi ont
ressenti la même chose au final à force
d'explorer des questions dont il ne
devait pas se mêler et qui vont au-delà
de leur simple condition de mortel Adam
éthanos vont totalement annihiler sans
faire exprès la réalité et ce sera le
cas également pour ceux de l'autre
univers notre Thanos sera dans
l'obligation de tuer notre Adam Warlock
pour tout rebâtir et de l'autre côté la
dame Warlock de l'autre univers devra
faire la même chose mais cette fois-ci
avec son anneau malheureusement cela ne
va pas du tout se passer comme prévu là
où Thanos et l'autre Adam pensait avoir
réparé ce qu'ils ont causé ils ont en
fait ramené la réalité 616 à son état
d'origine mais sans son Adam Warlock
celui que nous suivons et a contrario
l'autre Adam a absorbé inconsciemment la
totalité de son univers pour finalement
atterrir dans le nôtre tout ceci va
éveiller l'intérêt de l'antagoniste
Annie Luce qui depuis son vaisseau a
capté la trace d'une source illimitée de
pouvoir il s'agit bien évidemment du
Adam alternatif après avoir tué ses
opposants y compris Thanos et capturer
le Warlock omnipotent nous faisons face
à une ellipse de trois mois Thanos est
finalement revenu encore une fois la vie
grâce à son amour la mort elle-même il
va pouvoir être témoin de ce qui s'est
passé pendant son absence et attention
c'est un véritable carnage Galactus le
dévoreur de monde est mort l'Empire cri
est éteint tous les Célestes ont été
massacrés que ce soit les êtres
cosmiques ou les simples êtres vivants
la plupart ont été annihilés seule une
poignée d'Avengers ont survécu mais
comment un tel dénouement a pu se
produire et bien la raison est simple vu
que le Adam worlock alternatif absorbé
l'entièreté de son univers et bien cela
veut dire qu'il attend lui tous les
fragments des êtres cosmiques qui
régissaient sa réalité et donc par
conséquent tous leurs pouvoirs c'est un
aspect que nous n'avons pas trop
développé mais dites vous que par
exemple Eternity qui est l'incarnation
du temps et bien il en existe un dans
chaque univers chaque réalité possède un
fragment d'éternity et si tous les
univers fusionnent et bien cela nous
donne l’éternity complet et ce que je
vous dis là cela s'applique à la
totalité des êtres cosmiques à
l'exception de certaines entités comme
le tribunal vivant par exemple ou là il
n'en existe qu'un dans tout le multivers
pour revenir à notre histoire Thanos va
finalement s'unir avec les Avengers pour
confronter Annie Luce mais
malheureusement tout le monde va mourir
à l'exception de Thanos et là où tout
espoir semble perdu pipe le troll le
seul et unique véritable amis d'Adam
Warlock va réussir à rentrer dans le
vaisseau danius et face à son ami Adam
il va tenter par tous les moyens de le
réveiller c'est alors que Warlock va
finalement ouvrir les yeux cependant le
réveil brusque du personnage va
malheureusement lui causer une crise et
contre toute attente Adam va détruire la
réalité que ce soit pipe le troll Annie
Luce les êtres cosmiques tout le monde a
disparu tout le monde excepté Thanos nos
deux personnages vont alors entamer une
conversation et chercher une solution
ils vont se rappeler que parmi les êtres
cosmiques il était fait mention d'une
personne au-delà de tout ce qui existe
grâce au pouvoir
omnipotent d’adam nos protagonistes vont
convoquer le One bovol et une fois face
à l'être divin Thanos va proposer un
deal de retour dans la réalité nous
allons être témoin que tout semble
revenu à la normale les planètes
détruites sont restaurées les
civilisations sont ramenées bref tout va
pour le mieux dans le meilleur des
mondes et dans un dernier au revoir Adam
Warlock va et le nôtre à la vie et
révéler qu'il doit maintenant remplir sa
part du marché faite avec le One bovol
en échange d'avoir tout réparé le Adam
Warlock désormais omnipotent a été
désigné par le One beauvall comme
nouveau protecteur du multivers Adam
Warlock de la réalité
19141 incarnera à ce jour le nouveau
tribunal vivant l'ancien ayant été tué
par les Beyonders
je trouve cet apogée complètement
incroyable pour le personnage bon bien
évidemment ce n'est pas notre Adam
Warlock qui devient le tribunal vivant
mais celui de la réalité 19141 possède
quasiment la même histoire donc c'est
tout comme le personnage qui a vu le
jour simplement pour agrémenter
l'histoire des comics des Quatre
Fantastiques à l'époque a finalement
réussi à se hisser parmi les entités les
plus importantes de l'univers Marvel Jim
Sterlin en reprenant l'histoire du
personnage va en faire l'une des entités
les plus marquantes de Marvel alors que
nous aurions pu avoir un énième être
artificiel sans saveur au contraire le
fait que Adam ne soit pas un homme ou un
être vivant comme les autres sera une
véritable force pour lui le personnage
est pur il est dénoué de tous les vices
qui composent la vie il n'est pas en
quête de pouvoir il n'est pas en quête
de grandeur Adam souhaite simplement
défendre la vie et j'aimerais vous faire
réfléchir un instant quelle est la plus
grande caractéristique physique que
possède Adam Warlock et bien c'est son
corps tout doré il est là en fait le
symbole l'or est un métal noble il
résiste à l'oxydation et la corrosion
mais il est également un métal précieux
sans oublier qu'il est un incroyable
conducteur électrique à l'image de
l'élément chimique Adam Warlock n'a
jamais été corrompu personne n'a jamais
réussi à briser son âme que ce soit le
Mans Beast megus Thanos le gant de
l'infini la gemme de l'âme tous ont
tenté et tous ont échoué et justement
c'est quelque chose qui le rend précieux
personne n'égale les valeurs et la force
de caractère d'Adam Warlock à tel point
qu'il sera même choisi écouter et
respecté par les dieux que de Marvel
eux-mêmes et de la même manière qu'un
conducteur entend qui élu Adam et l'une
des rares entités capables de réunir
derrière lui tout le monde en cas de
besoin que ce soit les super-héros de
Marvel mais aussi les dieux cosmiques il
fait l'unanimité Adam est un personnage
incroyable extrêmement profond et fort
en symbolisme et tout ce que je vous
raconte depuis le début de la vidéo et
bien c'est tout ça qui rend Adam Warlock
si unique
J'espère de tout cœur que la vidéo vous
aura plu la tâche n'était pas vraiment
aisée car à l'inverse des vilains qui
ont tendance à apparaître dans deux
trois comics puis de laisser leur place
à un autre méchant et bien là quand on
parle d'un héros et bien quand il est
dans sa saga il vit de nombreux
aventures qui sont répartis sur des
dizaines et des dizaines de comics et
c'est ce qui se passe pour Adam Warlock
dès les années 90 il y a énormément
d'autres comics intéressants mettant en
lumière Adam notamment avec les gardiens
de la galaxie d'autres ou sa relation
avec Thanos sera approfondie etc etc
mais voilà j'estime qu'avec ce dont nous
avons parlé il y a largement moyen de
comprendre toute l'unicité qui composent
le personnage d'Adam Warlock si mon
travail vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
laisser un très beau pouce bleu qui
m'encourage énormément un commentaire
également à propos du personnage si
c'est une entité que vous aimez s'il y a
des comics qui vous ont marqué le
concernant bref je suis très curieux
vous lire et puis surtout n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner car d'autres vidéos de
ce type arrivent très prochainement sur
ce que le lion hard soit avec vous merci
de tout cœur d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
c'était argot rock allez ciao tout le
monde
[Musique]